thomas sotto il est le président du
parti des républicains christian jacob
est donc l'invitée de l'actualité de rtl
soir il ya l'émotion immense légitime à
la hauteur de l'horreur il ya les mots
si nous sommes en guerre contre les
ennemis de l'intérieur a dit le ministre
de l'intérieur ils ne passeront pas ou
encore la peur va changer de camp a dit
emmanuel macron et il ya le sentiment
sentiment d'impuissance face à une
situation qui semblent nous échapper
bonsoir christian jacob
bonsoir bienvenue à vous une fois qu'on
a dit ça et sans tomber dans le caca ou
dans le faucon dans la facilité on fait
quoi on fait quoi pour empêcher que ces
actes se multiplient que ses ennemis de
l'intérieur passe à l'acte écoutez on
passe on passe à l'action
passez à l'action ça veut dire se donner
les moyens juridiques les moyens
judiciaires les moyens policiers d'être
en lutte et d'être en guerre de répondre
cette guerre se basait sur les versions
sommes en guerre écoutez oui que les
actes que l'on suivi aujourd'hui sont
des actes de des actes de guerre et est
donc il faut passer à l'action passée à
l'action ça veut dire définir un cadre
juridique
la semaine dernière le ministre de
l'intérieur nous invite il invite les
présidents de jardiner et les
responsables des groupes politiques
rien n'était possible la semaine
dernière moi j'ai évoqué les les les
sujets sur l'immigration on ne peut pas
poser le problème de l'islamisme radical
sans poser le problème de l'immigration
vous fait un lien direct entre islamisme
et immigrés l'immigration oui écoutez
évoqué aujourd'hui le l'islamisme
radical
le communautarisme en dix ans qui n'a
pas de lien avec l'immigration
c'est se voiler la face la réalité
française
mickaël larpe ongs et l'uqam et bien sûr
qu'un débris s'étaient france et bien
sûr une réponse à leurs bureaux simplice
non non c'est pas une réponse un peu
trop simpliste le laxisme sur notre
politique d'immigration c'est ça la
responsabilité c'est le laxisme sur
notre politique d'immigration qui nous a
conduit à ce que ça veut dire
aujourd'hui qu'il faut se donner les
moyens de fermer les lieux de culte qui
sont radicalisées sur la base de la loi
de 2000
17 qui a fait suite à l'état d'urgence
vous savez combien de lieux de culte on
a fermé depuis trois ans sept sur une
centaine qui sont référencés identifié
par le ministère de l'intérieur
pourquoi on en est à 7 parce que le
fondement de la loi ne le permet pas
nous avons fait d'ailleurs à l'époque il
faut une loi plus simple plus permissive
oui c'est pas une loi plus permissive
mais c'est une une loi qui nous permette
effectivement les fermetures juridique
le cadre juridique qui est proposée
aujourd'hui n'est pas adapté nous avions
c'est ça va changer leurs majors avec la
loi sur le séparatisme la semaine
dernière c'était absolument impossible
puisque gérald darmanin nous a dit qu'il
y aurait rien sur l'immigration il
savait d'ailleurs la semaine dernière
pas identifié m'a demandé comment
identifier
juridiquement un lieu de culte c'était
ça le sujet de la semaine dernière donc
j'imagine à j'ose espérer qu'on est
passé à autre chose et quand qu'on va
effectivement travailler sérieusement
sur ce domaine
de la même façon hélas la semaine
dernière gérald darmanin votre place et
il a dit on parle d'une école de bobigny
qu'elles avaient été fermés pour des
raisons d'hygiène et que justement il
fallait faire changer la loi pour
pouvoir la fermer pour cause de
radicalisation il était favorable que la
semaine dernière nous a prétendu que ça
n'était pas possible dans le cadre de la
loi donc j'espère qu'il a qu'il a évolué
de la même façon que sur les expulsions
nous avons aujourd'hui 4000 étrangers
4100 je croise les chiffres du ministère
de l'intérieur
des signalements pour la prévention de
la radicalisation caractérise le fsr
péter laul voilà en fichez 4000 là on
nous annonce qui va y en avoir
semble-t-il 200 ou 230 qui vont être
qu'ils vont être expulsés et les 3800
haute on en fait quoi en fait en 1671
6,61 qu'on fait l'objet d'une mesure
d'éloignement et 428 d'expulsion qui ont
déjà été effectués
oui mais là concrètement sur les sur les
4000 si j'ai bien compris les chiffres
du ministre l'intérieur et à 200 qui
vont être expulsés bon allons partir il
faut aller plus vite c'est ça il faut
les plats sortir du moment où ces
individus sont en lien avec des
mouvements islamistes qui prônent la
haine et la violence pour pas dire le
meurtre qu'est-ce qu'ils font encore sur
notre territoire
s'ils sont étrangers qu'est ce qu'il
faut sur notre territoire
bientôt pas y avoir deux
débat là dessus de la même façon que sur
les les mineurs isolés et voulait
renvoyer y compris dans des pays comme
la syrie ou la libye quand ils sont
riches se donner les moyens de lutter à
partir du monde d'abord les les blast
est pas le cas mais sur les binationaux
moi je pense qu'il faut revenir sur la
déchéance de nationalité
françois hollande n'a pas le courage
d'aller au bout il en avait eu l'idée
mais n'a pas eu le courage d'aller au
bout il faut revenir sur cette déchéance
de nationalité
ensuite sur la libye ou la syrie nous
avons fait aussi des propositions sur ce
sujet d'un tribunal international qui
permet effectivement de pouvoir les deux
de pouvoir les juger on pourrait très
bien le faire on peut aussi conditionné
leur tour un pays parce qu'on a un
certain nombre d'individus qu'on veut
expulser mais encore faut-il qu un pays
d'accueil
eh bien il faut mettre des conditions
réelles ambitions les conditions c'est
par exemple est dos au développement
l'aide aux pays en voie de développement
on donne l'aide à condition que les pays
acceptent le retour de leurs
ressortissants
on peut le faire sur lui la politique
des visas également à jeudi on peut
trouver des moyens coercitifs
est-ce que vous il veut se donner tous
les tous les moyens de
de lutte il faut aller au bout de la
même façon que sur le voile jacques
chirac parce que vous parlez d'expulsion
est ce que comme marine le pen vous
dites qu'il faut expulser tous les
fichiers s est rangé jeudi
d'abord ceux qui sont étrangers et qui
sont sur le fichier des radicaliser nous
étions je pensais pas le même feeling au
c'est pour ça que je vous parle vichy
elle est affichée de renseignements je
vous parle moi de ficher des gens qui
sont sur le fichier des radicaliser pour
cause de prévention de lutte contre le
terrorisme
ça n'est pas rien on n'y est pas par
hasard sur ce cliché les les services
font bien leur travail et donc si on est
dessus et qu'ils sont étrangers je ne
vois pas ce qu'il faut sur le sol
français
les fichiers c'est ça un cadre beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus large et il y à aussi
il y aurait d'ailleurs beaucoup à dire
aussi sur les moyens à mettre à
disposition que je sois sur les
bracelets nouvelle génération avec les
gps etc
sally se passe pas rien christian jacob
le gouvernement veut fermer de
nombreuses associations gérald darmanin
veut la dissolution de baraka city ou
encore du collectif contre
l'islamophobie en france le ccf
c'est une bonne chose de faire mais ces
associations oui bien sûr mais
simplement depuis trois ans pourquoi on
n'a rien fait depuis 2015 j'ai compté ce
matin nous avons déposé 30 cette
proposition de loi pour lutter contre le
terrorisme au nom du groupe des
républicains dont une que j'avais déposé
mois au mois deux mois de juillet 2017
ou 2018 d'une part dont 2018 qui était
une loi qui rassemble l ensemble de nos
propositions
aucune proposition ne trouve grâce ne
trouvait grâce aux yeux de ce
gouvernement
alors je note peut-être que depuis
toujours les choses ont changé en avant
n'est pas responsable de tous les
problèmes on voit bien que rond dans une
situation qui a mûri qui a pourri dans
certains quartiers depuis des années
voire des décennies
oui enfin ramenant les choses à ce
qu'elles sont 2 soit 275 mille titres de
séjour sur l'année 2019 nation fait la
comparaison avec les années sarkozy
c'est 50 % de plus sur le 130 milles
demande de demande d'asile c'est une
augmentation de 50 % en trois ans le sou
nous sommes le voting de ce gouvernement
est laxiste mais complètement nous
sommes le premier européen en demandant
nombre de demandeurs de droit d'asile
dans tous les autres pays sa baisse et
nous ça explose depuis trois ans rien
n'est fait je veux qu'on écoute jean luc
mélenchon pour le patron de la france
insoumise de problème c'est les
tchétchènes
moi je pense qu'il ya un problème avec
la communauté tchétchène en france donc
je pense qu'il faut reprendre un par un
tous les dossiers des tchétchènes
présent en france et que tous ceux qui
ont une activité sur les réseaux sociaux
comme c'était le cas de l'assassin ou
d'autres qui sont des activités de
l'islamisme politique doivent être
capturés et expulsé voilà c'était hier
chez nos confrères de si c'est pas
dangereux de dire d'un bloc je pense qui
imprimait clip shenzhen chine le sujet
c'est pas celui là
le sujet c'est l'islamisme radical et
les prêches pour la haine et la violence
et le meurtre
c'est ça le sujet quelle que soit la
nationalité des ressortissants nous
devons avoir des peines et des sanctions
adaptées pour ceux qui sont français et
pour pour ceux qui sont étrangers
également et il faut le prendre dans son
ensemble s'agit pas partie de ceux qui
accusent le leader de la france
insoumise d'être ambigu sur l'islamisme
ou pas
écoutez je pense que son son discours
gagnant clarification bon ça semble être
le cas depuis quelques jours mais on
peut dire
à défaut de de jean luc mélenchon un
certain nombre de ses amis ont pas été
très clair sur le sujet vous pensez à
qui je pense à différents parlementaires
je pas dit non parce que tout simplement
j'étais plus en tête mais la réalité on
le voit à chaque à chaque débat à
l'assemblée où différentes différentes
manifestations
bon jean luc mélenchon a souvent été
plus prudent que le sont ses amis
seconde où on est dans une époque qui ne
fait pas dans la nuance christian jacob
comment faire pour éviter que les
musulmans de france se sente stigmatisé
tous mis dans le sac du terrorisme et
bien justement en luttant contre le
terrorisme
c'est le seul moyen vous avez 80 depuis
tout à l'heure la lutte contre le
terrorisme si on vous écoute c'est la
lutte contre l'immigration qu'est ce que
vous faites pour lutter contre les
français ces musulmans radicaliser c'est
la lutte contre le laxisme en matière de
politique migratoire
c'est ça le premier sujet parce que
m'expliquer que ça n'a pas de lien avec
le communautarisme et que le
communautarisme n'a pas le lien avec le
terrorisme on note bien savoir comment
me l'expliquer en place du programme est
oui c'est une partie significative du
problème ensuite vous avez les lieux de
culte et sur les lieux de culte
salafistes ou tenu par les frères
musulmans
je vous dis une centaine de lieux de
culte qui sont identifiés aujourd'hui en
trois ans ce gouvernement ferme 7
donc je vois pas au nom de quoi les 93
autres pourquoi ils sont toujours on
peut toujours il y prêcher la haine et
la violence et ça c'est pas un sujet
d'immigration
c'est un sujet des prêches pour la
violence et la haine est donc le seul
moyen de répondre et de faire en sorte
d'assurer dire l'inquiétude légitime de
tous nos deux compatriotes musulmans
c'est de lutter sans merci contre le
radicalisme contre ces prêcheurs de
haine
les auteurs d'actes violents marine le
pen demande de la création d'une
commission d'enquêté parlementaire pour
faire la lumière sur les responsabilités
après l'attentât de vendredi est ce que
vous appuyer cette demande de création
d'une commission d'enquêté de sa soeur
elle a droit comme chaque groupe nous
nous avons déjà notre une commission
denquête hausse et chaque groupe
parlementaire déposé une commission
denquête est-ce qu'il faut une
commission d enquête sur ce qui s'est
passé vendredi
je pense que il faut en tout cas qu'il y
ait une enquête en tirer tous les
enseignements enfin j'ose espérer c'est
ce qui est fait d'ailleurs on a vu qu'il
y avait un certain nombre de garde à vue
qui avait annoncé ce qui ce qui m'a
profondément inquiété mais j'ai pas
peut-être suffisamment d'éléments c'est
la protection de l'enseignant et la
protection de nos enseignants de manière
générale j'ai le sentiment sur ce qu'on
a pu voir dans la presse c'est que o2 en
dehors de son chef d'établissement le
sentiment que l'enseignant n'a pas été
protégé par sa hiérarchie donc je pense
qu' il serait important de faire la
lumière sur sur ce sujet on se doit
d'assurer la protection qui a peut-être
une responsabilité de la hiérarchie de
l'établissement en tout cas ça mérite
d'être clarifiée il faut poser la
question où est charlie ou pas christian
jacob
j'aime pas c'était ses expressions
je suis ce que je sais ce que je suis et
je suis un opposant déterminé à
l'islamisme radical et à tous ces actes
de violence mais aujourd'hui au nom de
la liberté d'expression vous pourriez
poster les caricatures sur votre compte
twitter par exemple nos deux chevaux
n'ont jamais je n'ai j'ai participé aux
manifestations au lendemain de cet
attentat odieux scandaleux bon il n'y a
pas de mot pour le pour le définir mais
je me suis jamais défini comme charlie
pour autant je n'ai d'ailleurs jamais
acheté une seule fois ce journal merci
beaucoup avoue christian jacob d'être
venu ce soir dans rtl soir à suivre ce
sera l'oeil de natacha polony a tout de
suite